i'm here with my trusty co-pilot ross
matthews
great day i mean we are really giving
the golds and the maroons and the
butters i know we look like we're head
of the class i know
or the partridge family hiking to the
back of this can we just do it hello oh
so cute
um we also wanted to take some questions
and maybe kick off another edition of
say it ross drew and a
and our first question is from claire
claire hi oh my gosh gosh hi clay hi
ross okay so i just moved here from
california just like you guys kind of
and i currently go to fit
oh fast and students yes okay and i just
got here too so i'm starting to like
look into internships and stuff like
that and i need your guys opinion okay
what's the question what shoe do you
think would be the most impressionable
walking into like an interview or
something for the fashion industry i say
the more fun the better i would do the
red
boot i'm all about the red boot red boot
that is a fantastic red boot also the
biggest trend going on right now i love
a cowboy boot it girls are wearing the
cowboy boots so it shows you're like up
on the latest and greatest trends
no one's kicking butt in an open toe you
know what i am
yeah
so wear that and i also love the
versatility in that you could wear a
legging tucked in you could do a wide
leg jean you could do a a dress with
that as well it looked very cool lots of
options yes thank you we are both
falling on the sword for the red boot
and good luck good luck thank you thank
you reporting back to us thank you how
it's going out there oh of course okay
thank you i'll report back okay guys
keep it on the loop clear
all right uh up next is donald and he's
got a real dilemma drew right here in
the front row look at donald's shirt for
starters who are you wearing uh yeah i'm
wearing this drew barrymore
[Applause]
and if you can't tell i'm your number
one fan i even got to take a selfie with
you once while wearing this shirt at
watch what happens live so i thought
that was the best moment of my life no
it's this oh so
that's so cute but i have a dilemma that
i would love both of your help with yeah
i just want to say i assume that you're
wearing ross matthews underwear
yes i am i fortunately can't show it to
the audience right now it's daytime
all right so what's your question okay
so my boyfriend loves to go out to a
fancy meal uh but i need some advice
canceling a dinner date with him
because i want to spend so much time
with him but when you're gay you go out
and you split the meals and they're
super expensive so i just want to
convince him to stay and
cook and watch charlie's angels
you wouldn't have to convince me i mean
not to sit around and watch my own
movies part but like i am totally that
girl i just want to like take out
tv
couch so let me ask you a question yeah
do you have plans tonight are you
supposed to go out we have plans
literally tonight to go out to a nice
dinner and i just need to convince him
like why don't we just stay in okay
should we call him
yeah
can we call him i feel like he'd be very
shook by that yeah
okay great give us your phone come on
i'll call him
do it
okay
you push it what do i push oh this is
him i'm gonna call and put it on speaker
what's his name peter okay peter okay
hello oh um hey peter
hey hey it's ross matthews and drew
barrymore calling hi peter
hi
hi
um we're we're here with um
donald and some friends
hey so you guys have plans tonight right
yeah we do
yeah i don't know about that
well
well ross and i were talking and we
thought um
that we were gonna do this experiment
this social experiment um with everybody
that we happen to be with right now so
um and and the social experiment is how
much can you
hang out at home and cook this month
yeah it's not that fun
that does sound fun
[Laughter]
well it's sort of like um an experiment
where we're all gonna like journal about
it and see like at the end of 30 days
what
what we like more going out or staying
home that's good wow
and
yeah i think staying in would be fun um
get to hang out with donald so that
would be fun too there you go
okay everyone say bye peter
peter
let us know how it's going and we'll
we'll talk to you guys and then um we'll
we'll collaborate at the end of the
experiment
okay sounds good okay thanks peter we
love donald oh yeah he's super cute
congratulations on your life
well i will have no problem keeping my
end up at the experience
that's for sure that's like how i
thought of it
i literally just came out with that like
i was like idea idea idea okay social
experiment you know what's so funny i
have reservations tonight with
wellington at a fancy restaurant
and i'm like well you're not part of the
experiment thank god because i've been
looking forward to all week
thank you for your questions you guys
thanks claire and donald i hope ross and
i were able to
be of any kind of service i think we
helped
yes
[Music]